bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo episodio di minecraft nel server
migliore del mondo di minecraft dove
perché qua c'è un'altra sigla tempo dove
abbiamo non sono amico lo spread e 23 17
che come volete vedere talmente attirato
dalla canna da pesca con il fungo che ci
sta praticamente sopra mai mi sembra
corretto perché dal momento in cui ti
faccio un regalo leggere tutte le
inglobi nel deretano perché vedo che ce
l'hanno nel li abbiamo un sacco di roba
tra diamanti cose oggi volevo fare un
paio di cose divertenti
facciamo ad onna di dio vota roma regala
non è mi accesi e mia ma c'e non l'ho
trovata io questa me l'hanno regalata ai
ragazzi del server non so chi è che
trova tutto sto diamante che ci ha
provato reparti come ragazzi allora la
partenza secondo me le ceste di partenza
dovrebbero a parer mio essere oggetto le
cose on the road senso cose importanti
che posso utilizzare che magari sto già
utilizzando per andare in giro per fare
le cose perché al pronti via io devo
prendere le robe che mi servono
innanzitutto carne o genitore roba un po
a caso quindi roba che non metto nel mio
archivio delle cose ok la latella
dell'animale yacht piazzano lanterna
così perché queste sono robe per
viandanti poche parole
andiamo subito al piano di sopra e
vedere se riesco allora qua tanto
tornano solo direi che va bene
bellissima la visuale sulla giungla
questa cosa mi fa impazzire non lo so
perché ragazzi mi piace troppo
allora boys vediamo se riesco a mettere
delle robe per bene allora a sinistra ad
attrito farei materiali quindi fanno a
destra materiale destra materiale quindi
ferro tutte ste robe qua tranne il
diamante ovviamente che lo ha messo in
una cesta segreta dopodiché ragazzi
allora lapislazzuli perfetto legno legno
legno vale come materiale materiali nome
legno 94 ed egli vada assolutamente tipo
qui legno e centrale al redstone la
metto qua ragazzi che non è proprio un
vero materiale però lo mettiamo lo
stesso la sun stone materiali vari
dobbiamo trovare un qualcosa per i
materiali vari
allora varietà io direi di farla tipo
così guardate
metto una cesta sopra la testa in modo
tale che ci sia il bari e ti perché se
noi diventiamo pazzi ragazza ci mettiamo
sei anni a fare tutto tipo qua dice non
posso farne roba solo per le scale
capito un po di roba va messa a cacchio
quest'anno queste vanno assolutamente di
sopra anzi no facciamo qualcosa delle
enchanting però mettiamo recenti che
faccia cagare questo è un ingente
protection 3 fortuna tre sono belle
personalissimi ma porto demonio vabbè
mettiamoli così poi troverò con
enchanting stupido devo ricordarmi che
tutto questo c'è ancora il piano ancora
sopra perché gli è pieno di chester haga
è però qua la mette così importanti di
sotto di allora la spada la metto qua
metto tutte le robe per scavare alla
fine ho fatto non ci stava la roba
ragazzi ho fatto una certa sopra gli
attrezzi dalla fina cambio tutto quanto
il cibo perché effettivamente ci
servivano roba del cibo le torce e le
mettiamo di sotto che cosa ci possono
stare sotto armatura ecco l'armatura la
metterei a questo punto
finora ci stanno le armature la c'è
segreta per raggiungerla devo andare
addirittura qua sopra una volta qua
sopra come avete visto nello scorso
episodio probabilmente basta andare
inside the bottle a name tag che non
servono a niente poi tutto il resto che
invece un po di utilità ce l'ha
ora la prima cosa che mi verrebbe da
fare è scrivere sul cartello perché
effettivamente non è stato scritto
ancora una marcia lo vedo come un
cartello d'entrata effettivamente qui in
poi è allora uno ha posto due a posto 3
posto e poi la casa del farli suonare la
campana
prima di entrare
se poi nessuno ti apre teneva fanchini
allora ragazzi ho preparato un po di
vernice che si possono fare in mind per
farvi vedere allora addirittura qua c'è
un divano con della roba sopra è
bellissimo vedere stesso realizza
restano ball divano la domenica dove
mettiamo un divano qua non si può
mettere secondo me o meglio si potrebbe
al posto di queste feste ovvero se non è
sono meglio le ceste ragazzi con cui
adesso vediamo di tutto abbiamo prendere
gli oggetti per fare il divano che
stanno di sopra potrei anche pensare
madonna che bella casa mia mamma mia che
bella casa bella casa mano grande march
sei un fenomeno cakic figo sottoposto
allora divano qua sotto
ah no di sopra mannaggia ho sbagliato ma
si qua ci sta da regalo faccio lo stesso
lo fa lo stesso alphaville divano lo fa
lo stesso guarda guarda la guarda la 1
arriva qua divano né ti metti a guardare
la gente che sale finito basta divano
del mondo finito bene altra roba che
possiamo fare divano lascia un po per
adesso non divano di never poi troverò
troverò a motori tv di cambiare lettera
con qualcosa di decente però non marito
a meno che non sia qua questa cosa che
non serve né dentro thorium a me fa non
ci sia 4 con il demonio
e vabbè distruggo tutto vediamo il legno
già non è mai forse è meglio il legno
non lo so vi dico che posso utilizzare
per ora solo al nettare la cava bene
così tanto poi cambierò in qualche modo
bene altre robe un po più piccole
bellissimo il tavolo di pistoni kohler o
belgi no ragazzi finale dobbiamo fare un
check quartz 2 qua è però il problema
dell'eccesso e c'è anche la carta
igienica
ma il problema del cesso e che non so
dove metterlo in casa mia sono belle
tutte le cose ma non so effettivamente
dove metterle perché comunque è tutto
strutturato al minimo cioè le
decorazioni dei dovrei mettere come si
fanno i quadri o to mail che sport
minecraft degli stick con in mezzo della
lana ok non avevo la minima idea ad ora
andiamo a prendere gli stick e con i
mezzi della lana e facciamo il resto è
l'unico modo per abbellire casa ragazzi
non ne vedo altri allora ghazi dell'ara
prendiamo subito questo che è il banner
che sicuramente ci serve è uno strumento
quello che ci servirà più tardi nono
nolana in tutto sto calcio tutto a tre e
comunque dovrei legare una volpe perché
per avere una casa bella la volpe ci sta
non si sa per quale motivo ma la volpe
per la per avere una casa perfetta ci
sta intanto metto questo tac che però è
marrone non se non sono decorati di
banner perché sono tutti i giusti li ho
messi nel posto giusto però sono marroni
interesserebbe averli colorati questi
qua non so se c'è un modo vabbè poi me
lo faccio dire da marciva ditemelo voi
nei commenti ragazzi
nel mentre vado sbaglio sempre vado a
prendere la lana per fare il porto ed
ecco l'altra tra pecora celo celo by
pecorella nella tempo di là nella ce
l'aveva già presa non offrono la presa
stava orco demonio porco candy candy che
devia e già ricresciuta che cacchio 6 e
li cresce ogni 4 secondi incredibile
blocchi di lana a posto e secondo me
bastano massa non si sa ma quanto c'è il
suo poco di crescere la nostra gola è
perfetto abbiamo fatto sono painting e
tutti diversi no ok perfetto quindi
possiamo mettere effettivamente i
painting che io non disdegno
effettivamente non ne ho mai disegnati
però magari non spacchiamo le cose che
c'è in casa che non ci ha messo una vita
a fare grazie prego
ok allora painting di qua va bene senti
in viva bene
manco a farlo apposta va benissimo si
può fare per lungo si perfetto anche qua
ci sta e la madonna
il mio di calma a te li mette proprio
lui utilizza lo spazio che ha cacchio e
non era così una volta la lega una volta
che li metteva a caso mi ricordo e si
utilizza lo spazio che a me thun dirt
quando vogliono da due gli facciamo così
vabbè è bastato la stavamo lo primo che
non si fosse un po più centrato dalla
senso ma anche noi siamo messi giusti
ragazzi siamo messi giusti sono molto
soddisfatto mancano assolutamente manca
una volpe devo prende una volta dopo
rubare una volta qualcuno a rubare una
volta stessa non scherzano fa guardavo e
basta mi sento troppo in colpa per
andiamo a vedere un attimo la casa lista
che comanda wright ragazzi abbiamo un
sacco di roba ancora da fare però
effettivamente voglio vedere beh
comunque guarda che quella distanza è
più piccola mi serve fare però non è
brutta e a me piace tantissimo
volevo solo vedere se hanno
effettivamente da prestarmi un quadro no
vabbè non glie lo toglierei mai senza
saperlo senza dirglielo però giusto per
curiosità
niente quadro sti maledetti neanche un
banner decente guarda tutto marrone
comunque molto [ __ ] questa cosa
l'importante di tutto questo ragazzi e
che la casa più bella grossa sia la mia
niente da fare la gara ci vediamo nel
prossimo episodio abbiamo delle case
stupende io ripeto che sono tre eletti
se son in due staffe fair and spoilers
ci vediamo in un prossimo episodio
ragazzi lo serve invece un mi piace
anche lei sa che doveva iniziare sono
stati siete e noi come sempre ci hanno
bei ragazzi
[Musica]